i think what you're doing is nobel prize
winning work well thank you so much
that's very kind thank you i'm extremely
very much looking forward to this
thank you when i was researching you
about every 10 minutes or so you would
say this
some offhand comment that would
floor me because of its consequences and
then you'd move on and then you'd say
what trump's what came before and this
happened over and over
so why don't you start with
what non-neural bioelectric states are
their relationship to anatomical results
and then later we can compare and
contrast to standard developmental
biology for decades which is it's the
genome that instructs constructs perhaps
what's epigenetic so we'll start with
what are bioelectric non-neural
bioelectric states and their
relationship to anatomical results
sure uh okay well
so so non-neural bioelectrical states
are simply the fact that all cells in
your body not just neurons have the same
machinery that's normally associated
with neural cells so ion channels
electrical synapses neurotransmitter
pathways
all of these things are way older than
nervous systems and all every cell in
your body is creating an electrical
potential across its membrane most cells
in your body are communicating those
states to their neighbors via these
electrical synapses
and
on the one hand people are often
surprised to hear this on the other hand
if you ask yourself where did neurons
and brains come from they didn't just
spring up out of nowhere evolution
basically
uh speed optimized processes that were
already here around the time of
bacterial biofilms they're ancient these
things are ancient and so
uh
if you if you just uh sort of track back
the phylogeny of of of nervous systems
and neural cells you find out that all
cells have these and in fact we've had
discussions very lengthy discussions on
some of these basal cognition meetings
in terms of what is a neuron you know
people people will say well here are
neurons and i'll and i'll say by the way
what's a neuron and so they'll write on
the board four or five criteria for what
they think is a neuron and then they say
well every cell does this and so uh
there are a couple of there are a couple
of differences but but but most things
are fairly universal
and so then the question becomes we'll
find what are they used what is this
used for so in the brain what you have
is a system where an electrical network
is processing information to
direct muscles that move your body
through three-dimensional space that's
behavior nervous system control of
behavior
in
prior to that what these systems were
used for were to generate signals that
control cell behavior to move your body
configuration through anatomical space
that is the space of possible anatomical
configurations so i think um and i'm
working on some more stuff on this now
in terms of really broadening this this
idea but but i think what evolution did
was pivot some of the same tricks
across different spaces so
electrical uh electrical networks were
used to
control to traverse uh first in
evolution probably first metabolic
spaces and then physiological spaces and
then transcriptional spaces and
amorphous spaces and eventually
three-dimensional space when muscles
came on the scene and yeah animals could
run around and do things like that
but uh that's that's what electrical
networks used to think about before they
thought about behavior in
three-dimensional space they thought
about navigating other types of space
now how does this compare to the
standard view which is just it's our dna
that programs us the the the the
standard view is correct in the
following sense what the dna specifies
is the structure of the micro hardware
of your cells so the dna gives you the
protein level uh sequence meaning the
the structure of the proteins that every
cell has that's the hardware so the dna
the dna is what specifies the hardware
of the cells now it turns out that that
hardware is awesome it's it's amazing in
the following way when you put that
hardware together it not only has
specific uh sort of default behaviors
but it also has lo it has computational
capacity and it's reprogrammable that
that's that's so that's actually one of
the most exciting parts about it but uh
the the the the the standard view is
that
you should be able to
very directly go from what's in the
genome to
the anatomical structures and i i think
what that view is missing is a very
important middle layer that sits between
the hardware and the of the anatomy of
the hardware of the genome rather and
the final outcome this the santa these
this anatomical homeostasis that we see
in regeneration and development and so
on and that layer is the software it's
the physiological software that that uh
that links those two things together